a historian of nuclear weapons
and today I'm here to talk about the
science behind Oppenheimer
[Music]
so that's a saying of them assembling
the gadget this is clearly based on some
pictures that have come out and they're
not a ton of pictures showing this level
of assembly that have been Declassified
and released all the pictures we have of
this are black and white the people who
actually saw it described it as being a
sort of peach colored sort of tan
colored each of those wedges are several
layers of high explosive so there are
sort of variants of TNT called explosive
lenses and they are putting them around
the plutonium sphere that powers the
whole thing this is about the size of a
grapefruit
so plutonium solid metal imagine you had
a piece of Steel and I said push it on
all sides to make it smaller you need to
shrink it by half its size exactly
symmetrically each of these are the
detonators when they all go off they're
going to start a shock wave through this
device it's going to start going in in
inside that little sphere plutonium is
even tinier sphere of polonium and
beryllium this thing if you compress it
will shoot out some neutrons that's
meant to just start the reaction you
push the whole thing together and make
an atomic bomb explode this is called
implosion
one of the things we see in the movie is
the final assembly of the gadget this is
based on actual footage that was taken
at the time even the lighting looks like
in the historic footage that we have
this is a 100 foot Tower they've brought
the explosive sphere out to the test
site by the tower and they put a big
tent around it you need this thing to be
as controlled as possible if you got a
pebble in there it could deform the
shock wave by just enough to make the
whole thing either not work or not work
very well so they want this to be a very
pristine sort of environment which is
hard to do when you're in the middle of
the desert they're putting in in the
scene What's called the tamper plug the
goal is to have this sit right around
the plutonium core in the middle of the
bomb this is a delicate operation this
tamper plug arguably is worth 400
million dollars in 1945 money they don't
want to mess this up because once you
put the plutonium in there every little
step of getting it closer to being a
bomb makes it a little bit more
dangerous to be around and radioactively
you know problematic this core is like
on the edge of being explosive it's also
Radioactive It's also hot plutonium in
that quantity is so radioactive that
it's about 80 degrees Fahrenheit they're
dropping it through the center of the
bomb they've made a sort of trap door
basically into the bomb so that the lens
on top can come out you can drop this
thing in in real life they went to put
it in and it didn't fit oh my God if we
have we totally messed this up wait a
minute wait a minute it had to be the
right temperature for it to fit the
outer part was cooler than the inner
part was and so they had to wait for
them to reach the same temperature and
then it just slid into place
so there had to be one person left in
the tower to set it all up at the very
end stay with the bomb do the final
connections and then head back and this
was of course a very stressful job they
had previous mock-ups that were set off
by lightning in the distance so they're
in a very precarious State here
there's a scene before the actual
Trinity test where General Groves is
asking Oppenheimer about the possibility
of this test destroying the world
there's a chance that when we push that
button we destroy the world one of the
real concerns was this problem of what
they called atmospheric ignition what if
the nitrogen and oxygen in the
atmosphere fuse together and release
energy could they release enough energy
that that would trigger more nuclear
fusion that then goes over the entire
globe and leaves it a burnt horrible
Cinder turns out that kind of equation
is really hard to do but let's imagine
that it's like a hundred times easier
than we think it is we can sort of make
very conservative extrapolations and we
find it's it's probably not going to
happen chances are near zero near zero
what do you want for Theory alone
Oppenheimer is giving the correct
scientist answer they basically
concluded it would be less than one in
three million something like that in the
1970s weapon scientists redid those
calculations could you set the Earth on
fire if you wanted to yes but you need
bombs that would be hundreds of
thousands of times more explosive than
any bombs we ever made and you'd need to
have much higher proportion of the ocean
be made out of a rare isotope called
deuterium a different type of hydrogen
if you had this you could indeed turn
the earth into a sun
the detonation took place very late at
night they wanted to see exactly how
bright it was and it's going to be
harder to see that in the daytime when
you're competing with the actual Sun
they actually had recommended that the
bombs be dropped on Japan at night
because they would be more
psychologically stunning but for
logistical reasons they were dropped in
the morning on both of the Cities
so those numbers you see are Nixie tubes
those are a free digital way to display
numbers it's a very nice period
appropriate touch so at this point the
gadget as they called it is fully
assembled you can tell that because the
wires are sticking out the top on the
front that's called The X unit that's
the firing unit it's assembled to set
off this kind of bomb you have to send a
high voltage electrical signal to 32
separate places at exactly the same time
nanosecond tolerances on the timing to
have it work right and then they have a
wire going all the way back to base camp
and if you hit the big button on the
wire
you're telling the bomb go ahead and
explode it will
foreign
Oppenheimer the Trinity test is one of
the climax moments it's ridiculously
bright much much brighter than the
actual Sun what oppenheimer's putting on
here are welding goggles and these are
so dark that you really can't see
anything in them except something that
is as bright as the sun there were a few
people at the Trinity test who'd looked
at the explosion without anything over
their eyes one of them by accident he
dropped his goggles and one of them on
purpose they both suffered from what was
called flash blindness temporary
blindness you'll see a big dark spot
over your vision for quite some time
there were people who were relatively
close thousands of yards Oppenheimer and
the sort of control bunker much closer
than a lot of the outlying ones most of
the people there were instructed to lay
down away from the blast so that they
don't turn around and either get knocked
over or get a face full of dust
so the Trinity test was heavily heavily
documented both by pressure gauges and
cameras with telephoto lenses from a
very far distance but some of them were
closer in bunkers anytime you see a
close-up and it's sort of like a wall of
fire there are shots from the actual
training tests that look pretty similar
to that interestingly on some of the
very earliest shots where they were
trying to get the very first moments of
the fireball it was hot enough that it
burned holes in the film this particular
shot is interesting because this is what
they call in the business a rope trick
and they are only show up when you can
take pictures that are thousand frames
per second or something like this you
have a tower with a bomb on it and it's
got wires stabilizing the tower and
there's a little tendril of the fireball
that's going faster than the rest
because it's blowing up the wire as it
goes down there no one at Trinity could
have actually seen this what you're
seeing here is the complex interaction
that happens when the blast wave hits
the ground goes straight down bounces
back up and then intersects with that
blast wave coming out there's a really
big difference in how the blast wave
behaves from a bomb that's right on the
ground from one that's a little bit in
the air they want this What's called the
mock stem to have a wider area of
Destruction that's how you maximize the
blast pressure of detonating very high
above the ground they're going to use
that data to set the altitude of the
atomic bomb over Japan when they went
into the Trinity test they're sort of
best guess was it would maybe be 4 000
tons of TNT it ended up being more
powerful than they thought by a factor
of like five twenty thousand tons of TNT
equivalent this is enough to destroy a
sort of medium-sized City if you're a
much bigger city like say New York City
it's enough to destroy like Midtown so
this is one of the reasons why Trinity
is so important it's not just it works
they find out it works really well
so the Manhattan Project is this
gigantic Endeavor it's this massive
industrial project and employs like 500
000 people it's like one percent of the
civilian labor force and it costs like
two billion dollars in their money which
is like one percent of the whole cost of
World War II these one percent of all
the electricity in the country to make
these weapons they're building an
industry in like two and a half years
and the output of that industry is a
very tiny amount of material a six
kilogram plutonium core 13.5 pounds
that's the one they first test out
Trinity about 64 kilograms about 120
something pounds of Highly enriched
uranium uranium-235. that's for the bomb
that's going to be dropped on Hiroshima
and then they have one more plutonium
core that's the one they're going to end
up dropping on Nagasaki so all of that
effort is to make these three cores for
the bombs and they had one more
for sending it the war ended many of
these people talked about this as the
best years of their life in some ways
they had a lot of fun and some of them
felt quite guilty about that after
Hiroshima and Nagasaki
oppenheimer's a really complicated
character what he said he regretted was
that after World War II they continued
to make more weapons and they continue
to make bigger weapons and they continue
to make the kind of world that he
thought would ultimately put
civilization itself in danger in the
years to come it will be possible to
kill 40 million American people by the
use of atomic bombs in a single night he
knew in 1945 that there were ideas on
the table for bombs that would be
thousands of times more powerful and
that the nations of the world could all
get them if they wanted them and that a
war with bombs of that big could be
fatal for the entire species and so
that's the sort of paradox of
Oppenheimer this person who wants peace
but he does it through War